tawa
what I understand as the fear of Allah
or the being aware of Allah. Could you
explain this concept the concept of tawa
so the viewers will be able to take
maximum benefit from uh that information
that they could fast. As far as tawa is
concerned, just to give an example,
taqua is like if you're walking in a
very narrow lane which has got a lot of
thorns. There are plants and creepers
and trees with a lot of thorns and you
walk in that narrow lane trying to
prevent your clothes from getting stuck
in the thorn and getting torn. So how
well you do that that is an action of
tawa.
Linguistically
tawa comes from the Arabic root word
waka which means forbearance which means
fear which means abstinence. Islamically
it means fear of Allah. Islamically tawa
is the state of the heart of a human
being
and the consciousness of Allah subhana
wa t'ala
the consciousness of his presence and of
his knowledge which makes him do
the righteous deeds and it prevents him
from doing things which are haram and
makes him pious. That is the reason tawa
if you translate one word people
translate as god consciousness or
Allah's consciousness it's translated as
piety it's translated as righteousness
in short and tawa
actually as the blood prophet said it is
a shield
and tawa is a shield which prevents you
from the hellfire
and it prevents you from the punishment
of Allah subhana wa t'ala
and there are various verses of the
Quran which speak about taka. Allah says
in the Quran
in surah alan
chapter number three verse number 102
all you who believe have tawa of Allah
subhana wa t'ala and die not except in
the state of Islam. That means the
believers should fear Allah subhanana wa
tala and die not except in the state of
Islam. And Masud may Allah be pleased
with him. While giving commentary of
this verse, he says it means that the
believers have to obey Allah subhananaa
tala should not disobey him. They have
to remember him. They should not forget
him. They should be thankful to him and
they should not be ungrateful.
And
the criteria for judgment in the sight
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala for judging
any human being it is tawa. And Allah
says in the Quran injur chapter number
49 verse number 13
which means oh humankind we have created
you from a single pair of male and
female and have divided you into nations
and tribes so that you shall recognize
each
Not that you shall despise each other.
And the most honored
in the sight of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala is the person who has tawa. The
criteria for judgment in the sight of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala, it's not sex,
it's not color, it's not cast, it's not
money, it's not wealth, it's not age,
but it is tawa. It is God consciousness,
it is piety, it is righteousness. Only
way one human being can be superior to
the other, it is by tawa.
And our beloved prophet Masall wasallam
used to always encourage the Sabbah and
he always gave guidance to his
companions that they should increase in
taka and especially when they went on a
military expedition. He always said that
fear Allah have tawa and that was
followed later on by the Sahabas and
giving advice and
we also have a hadith of may Allah be
pleased with him. He told his son
Abdullah, may Allah be with him, that
have tawa
and fear Allah. And he said you fear
Allah and he will protect you. Have tawa
of Allah and he will protect you. And he
further said that if you give
in the way of Allah, Allah will reward
you. And if you thank Allah, he will
increase. Here we realize that there are
many verses in the Quran which Allah
gives us guidance about tawa. For
example, Allah says that tawa is the
criteria
for a person to acquire righteousness
and Allah to accept your deeds. Allah
says in the Quran in surah a haz chapter
number 33 verse number 70 and 71.
Oh you believe have tawa of Allah fear
Allah and those who obey Allah and his
messenger they are the people who will
achieve a great reward would have
reached a higher achievement.
Allah gives a similar message
in surah maida chapter number 5 verse
number 27 where Allah says that Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala accepts the acts of
those
those who fear Allah that means Allah
subhananaa tala accepts the deeds of the
people who have tawa
point number two those people who have
tawa they gain the pleasure and love of
Allah subhanaa tala as Allah says in
surah huja chapter 49 verse number 13
that the most honorable in the sight of
Allah is the person who has taka. Allah
says in the Quran in surah Imran chapter
number three verse number 76 whoever
fulfills his pledge and has tawa in
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. Indeed Allah
loves those of Allah loves those who
have tawa.
The third point as far as tawa is
concerned Allah says in the Quran that
because of tawa Allah subhanana wa tala
forgives your sins and he increases your
reward.
Allah says in the Quran in surah talak
chapter number 65 verse number five that
anyone who fulfills his duty and as tawa
Allah subhanana wa tala forgives his
sins he remits his sins and increases
reward.
The fourth point mentioned in the Quran
regarding tawa is those who have tawa
Allah keeps them on the straight path
and prevents them from deviation.
Allah subhanaa tala says in the Quran in
surah fal chapter number 8 verse number
oh you believe have tawa and Allah will
give you the furan furan means the
criteria to judge right from wrong and
there are various commentaries given
some people said that furan here means
the straight path some people of the
comment said that furan means paradise
So if you have tawa then you will go to
paradise. Further it's mentioned in the
Quran. Allah says in the Quran in surah
had chapter number 57 verse number 28
that those who have tawa and those who
believe in the messenger. Allah
subhanana wa tala gives them a light by
which they guided. So tawa keeps you on
the straight path and prevents you from
deviation.
How to achieve this tawa?
Allah says in the Quran in surah bakar
chapter number two verse number 21
oh humankind worship thy lord who has
created you and created those people who
came before you so that you may learn
tawa.
So if you worship your lord who has
created you and people who came before
you you will learn tawa. Allah says in
the Quran in surah bakar chapter 2 verse
number 183
Oh you believe
fasting has been prescribed to you
as it was prescribed to people who came
before you
so that you may learn self-restraint the
word so that you may learn tawa.
So here there are two examples given how
can you learn tawa. One example is we
worship Allah subhanaa tala and we know
salah is the best pillar that a Muslim
is supposed to offer salah.
He has to pray to Allah subhanaa tala
five times a day and this keeps him on
the straight path and this increases his
tawa. And the second thing one is the
daily activity and Ramadan fasting is
the annual activity like how a body
requires overhauling once every year.
Every machine requires servicing. Some
require once a summer month some require
quarterly some require yearly. And if
you allow me to call the human being a
machine it is the most complicated
machine on the earth. Don't you think it
requires servicing? So Ramadan is the
overhauling in the sourcing of the human
body body as well as soul once a year
during the month of Ramadan and this
increases the tawa it increases your god
consciousness righteousness piety as we
discussed in all these days and I'll let
you give an example
there was a sahaba
when Raman was coming Makkah used to be
very hot so he is traveling towards tif
just a couple of days before Ramdan
And there's a bedin who's traveling the
opposite direction from to Makkah. So
this sabah asked him that aren't you
afraid of the heat in Makkah during
Ramadan? So he says I am running away
from the hellfire. So that was his tawa.
So that gives an example of tawa. Who is
most righteous? Allah says in surah hajj
chapter number 22 verse number 32
whoever honors the symbols of Allah
subhana wa tala he is the person tawa.
Allah further says in surah bakar
chapter number two verse number 204 that
you may be dazzled with some people's
speech
and they may swear by Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala that the heart is clean but Allah
knows that these people the vicious
enemies of humankind Allah says in the
Quran talking about as the friend of
Allah subhanaa tala Allah says in surah
ununus chapter number 10 verse number 62
and 63 that those people who of tawa are
the people who are lay of Allah subhana
wa tala means a friend of Allah
subhanana wa tala that means those
people who have tawa fear Allah subhana
wa tala and love Allah subhanana wa tala
these are the people who are all of
Allah subhana wa tala Allah further says
in surah fa chapter number 8 verse
number 34 Allah says but most of them
realize not so these are the few verses
and many other verses which Allah's
mother speaks about tawa in the Quran